في هذه النافذه وهذا المباشر سنحاول ان
نركز على الوضع الانساني والمجتمعي لكل من
قدم الى بورت سودان في ظل الظروف الامنيه
خلال الساعات الماضيه والايام الماضيه نحن
الان نتحدث في هذا المباشر من حي هدل وهو
احد الاحياء بمدينه بورسودان من داخل هذه
الغرفه بمدرسه القابلات التي تحولت الى
مركز ياوي الضيوف هذه الولايه احد الذين
قدموا من بورسودان يحكي كيف وصل وكيف
اهتدى الى هذا المركز الذي يقدم خدمات
اجتماعيه لكل من قدم الى هذه المنطقه
مرحبا بكم مرحبا بالحدث ومرحب او ابننا
نزار وكل الطاقم وجزاكم الله عنا كل خير
معكم عبد الرحمن السيد ادريس من قاطني
الثوره الحاره العاشره وهو تحركنا يوم
الخميس
من العاشره ببصات الى عطبره ومن عبره
استقلنا البسط الى بورسودان وصلنا الى
الخميس والمساء كيف الوضع الان هنا في هذا
المركز الذي يقدم دعم وسنه شعبي من ابناء
بورسودان وابناء الحي لكل الضيوف الذين
وصلوا الى هذه المنطقه والله انا اشيد
اشاده كامله
بالشباب وبالشيوخ يعني تفانوا في خدمه
النزلاءهم ايواهم ايواء كامل يعني كامل
بمعنى الكلمه يعني يعني من ناحيه الاكل
والشرب
والعلاج وكل كل شيء يعني واستقبال طيب
يليق بالاسره السودانيه يعني
شكرا جزيلا سنحاول ان ننتقل الى جانب اخر
لنقدم ايضا اضاءه ونقدم صوره لواقع الامر
هذا التجمع الذي تشاهدونه الان هو
لابناء هذا الحي الذين يتشاورون في كيفيه
مواصله هذا السند وهذا الدعم
اداريه بهذه المنطقه وهي ام رؤوف تقدم
ايضا دعمها وهي احدى القائمات على امر هذه
المدرسه مدرسه القابلات او امي كيف الحال
اهلا وسهلا كيف تحولت تحول المركز لمركز
يقدم خدماته لكل ضيوف الولايه المدرسه دي
اول كانت مهجوره لها
سنحيف
مزمل قال لينا المدرسه اتصلوا بان وزاره
الصحه قالوا اليوم خلاص استلموها ناس شباب
الحيه كانت مهجوره نظفوها
وطلبوا الدعم من الناس الحي بذاتهم جابوا
الحاجات هنا فطور غدا عشاء ناس السوق ديل
بيجيبوا اللبن بيجيبوا الرز بيجيبوا العدس
ما في حاجه ناقصان هنا نحن بواجبنا
والحريم اللي حوالينا المركز بيجوا ياخدوا
معانا زايد النسوان القاعدين هنا كل واحده
بتجي بتعود سعوسه بتطبخ تطبخ ونيجي نوزع
للناس القاعدين هنا لكن
التوزيع بعد نوزعه بنوزعه وعندنا ناموسيات
نحن وزعناه وفي ناموسيات جاب لنا عبد
الرحمن بلال برضو ايوه جهدي شعبي لكن ما
جايانا من الحكومه ولا لكن في ناس مفتكرين
لكن شعبي رسمي اذكرهم
شباب على
الحمد لله نشير ايضا بان عدد من الاسر
الان وصلت الى هذا المركز تقدم الخدمات
يقدم الدعم ويقدم السند هنالك وجبات طعام
لثلاث مرات تقدم في اليوم نحو 70 فرد وصل
الى هذه المنطقه وصل الى هذا المركز الذي
اصبح مركزا لاستقبال ضيوف ولايه البحر
الاحمر من جنسيات مختلفه من سوريا من
اليمن من السودان حتى من قدم من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم سنقترب اكثر من المركز
الذي يعاد فيه الطعام
لضيوف هذا المركز هذه هي غرفه العمليات
لصناعه الطعام هنا يقدم ويصنع الطعام
للضيوف على مدار اليوم تجتهد النسوه يجتهد
شباب الحي شابات الحي في تقديم الدعم في
تقديم الجهد الاكل والطعام ياتي من مختلف
البيوت المحيطه بهذا
المركز احد ايضا القائمين على هذا الامر
سيوضح اكثر
كيف يستمر وكيف يمضي هذا الدعم هل من جهد
اخر رسمي ام هو فقط من جهد ابناء هذا الحي
والله الجهد داء من ابناء الحي من الثورات
وهذل والبيوتات القريبه وجملنا في سوق
بتاع هذا كلهم بيتعاونوا معانا نحن جبنا
لهم بوتاجاز وتلاجه على اساس
77 اسره نعم نعم
وما في حاجه تجينا من برا كلنا برضو انه
موجود الان في عدد من الاحياء موجود طبعا
عدد من الاحيان موجود في حتات برضو فتحوها
في حداد كثيره يعني في حته اسمها
ومركز ثاني في داخليه بتاعت البنات هنا
وحدات كثيره يعني هذه هي الصوره المجتمعيه
لواقع مئات من الاسر التي
اضطررتها ان تكون هنا في مدينه بورسودان
هنالك من يحاول ان يغادر هذه المدينه الى
خارج السودان هنالك من يحاول ان يستقر في
هذه المدينه حتى تهدا الامور في العاصمه
وفي عدد من الولايات وبعدها يعودون الى
بيوتهم الى مساكنهم هذا هو الملمح وهذه هي
الصوره الخاصه والحصريه وهذه هي الصوره
بكل ما تحمل من معاني ومن تعبيرات لمتابعه
المزيد
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات